We are back with the comedy tag team of our dreams,
Casey Wilson and Danielle Schneider!
(audience cheering)
Yeah!
All right, let's hit those headlines,
because this is the news, after all,
and we love to source interesting facts,
things that are happening.
Casey, kick us off, please.
Okay. I will.
So honored to do this.
So first up, scorned Taylor Swift lover,
Jake Gyllenhaal, is speaking out.
(Ross chuckling)
"Elle" reports, Jake has not listened
to Taylor's Red album, or the song about him,
but he says it has nothing to do with him.
It's between Taylor and her fans,
and she uses her personal life in her music.
I feel like Jake gets it. Right?
But that being said, Jake did turn off
the comments on his Instagram when the album came out,
and about that, he said, and I quote here,
"I think it's important when supporters get unruly
that we feel a responsibility to have them be civil,
and not allow for cyber bullying in one's name."
In one's name.
I mean, I think we all know
the name that he means though
(audience applauding)
Right?
Well, yeah.
I think that part's great.
I will say, and I like Jake Gyllenhaal,
I just don't believe that he hasn't listened to the album.
Okay. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
(Casey laughing)
But if "Puff the Magic Dragon" was about me,
I would listen to it.
You know? And I would study every single lyric.
Do you think? Come on.
(Drew clearing throat)
You said what my thought bubble was,
which was, "You listened".
You listened!
You have no shame.
Wouldn't you guys listen,
if there was an album that was sort of about you?
Wouldn't you?
I do feel though,
I would listen, and he still has the red scarf. Right?
But I still feel like he is afraid of Taylor's army.
As am I.
I am too.
I mean, I feel like we could
send in Taylor's army instead of the National Guard.
I mean, they are terrifying.
Have you had, 'cause that,
what attracted me to this story,
was his saying, listen, all's fair in love and war.
However, cyber-bullying,
fans getting outta control.
That angle,
I kind of did appreciate.
Me too. Yeah.
Have you had interaction
with Taylor Swift fans?
Ah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have?
We might have made an errant
comment on the podcast.
And it was with so much
love and respect for Taylor.
Yeah.
And I want them all to know that.
Yes, and I will say that it was done
in the heat of the moment, and I meant no wrong,
and please don't come for me, I have a child
And this is a public apology actually.
Yes.
You heard it here first.
Yeah.
Daytime exclusive.
Danielle, your story.
Okay.
So everyone is freaking out over "The Tinder Swindler",
the new documentary on Netflix
about the guy who allegedly scammed his dates
out of hundreds of thousands of dollars.
He says it's, and I quote, "Not true."
But now, the "New York Post" reports,
he, the swindler himself, Simon Leviev,
just signed with an agent.
Now, you might think he'd be running under a rock to hide,
but nope, he is headed to Hollywood, baby!
Yeah!
And he's got big plans.
He wants a dating show
where women have to compete to date him.
What do we think?
(Danielle chuckling)
Well, okay, there are-
Do you know how long it took me to get an agent.
(group laughing)
Crazy, but I am tech avail
for any projects coming in.
(group laughing)
You know, I just think there are so many bad people
on dating apps, you know?
And at least this guy has a job.
You know what I mean?
Like, yeah.
Now!
He's a hustler. He's working.
He's on cameo, so he's working, at least.
Oh, god!
Yes!
I would like to-
You're attracted to him,
aren't you?
We feel about Penn, you feel about this guy.
I love how now, I'm like,
"I can't believe you'd accept that kind of behavior".
Meanwhile, we're drooling over Penn Badgley,
because he's, yeah, okay.
Now Ross,
we have a surprise coming out.
(Danielle laughing)
(Ross clapping)
It's The Tinder Swindler!
No, keep him.
Just good luck. Good luck.
All right, next up.
There's a new documentary in the works
about a true TV icon.
Do you guys all remember
the "Psychic Hotline" legend, Miss Cleo?
Right?
Yes!
I always wanted to call her now.
Every time she said it, I was like,
"Oh, I can't afford it."
Well, if you had a TV in the '90s, you couldn't miss her.
Here's a little reminder.
You have questions. I have the answers.
Well, the "Huffpost" reports,
the doc is gonna dig into the woman behind the psychic.
Her real name was Youree Dell Harris,
and reportedly, she wasn't a psychic from Jamaica.
She was an actress from LA.
What?
Yes!
No.
For reals.
The "Psychic Reader's Network"
pulled over $1 billion in revenue until 2002,
when, uh-oh, the Federal Trade Commission just sued them
for deceptive advertising and billing.
Oopsies, and the documentary is gonna dig into all of it,
and reveal more about Miss Cleo,
and whether she was an accomplice,
or perhaps, a victim in the fraud.
Billion dollar industry from Miss Cleo.
Wow.
I'm sorry.
When this documentary comes out, I'm gonna binge it now.
I can't wait for this.
Wow, I have to say, I'm glad that she's not around now,
because I would've spent all my money.
I'm into astrologers.
Oh, yeah.
I'm into psychics, the whole thing.
I went to a psychic once,
and I do love this stuff, but when I came out,
my car had been towed,
and I do wish she had told me that.
(group laughing)
(audience laughing)
It's so true.
Yeah.
Tell the case that.
Go around the corner
real quickly.
She's thinking
far in the future.
She's not thinking
five minutes from now.
Oh, that's it.
Well, I have to say, I'm really excited
by all these fascinating documentaries.
I feel like documentaries have always been around.
They're nominated for Academy Awards.
We love them.
We learn from them,
but I feel like they're just really
ever present right now,
and I can't get enough of them.
I'm on the documentary feeder.
(bright music)